[Music]
before we start this video I just wanted
to mention that only 19 percent of you
are subscribed so if you enjoy the
content please consider subscribing to
the channel hey everyone welcome to
another installment of Harry Potter
theory in this video I'm going to be
discussing Gellert Grindelwald in the
Patronus charm first we'll be looking at
whether or not he was actually capable
of producing one and next we will be
theorizing on what his Patronus animal
would be we first see Crenn the walled
in the Deathly Hallows
when're then much older Grindelwald
refused to give Voldemort the
information he needed regarding the
Elder Wand then we see him again when he
is much younger in fantastic beasts and
where to find him
followed by fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald Grindelwald was born in
the 1883 and in his younger years he was
a student at durmstrang
Institute while attending the school
Grindelwald demonstrated exceptional
magical ability however his sadistic
nature also shown through and he was
expelled for experimenting with twisted
and dark magic Grindelwald continually
pushed the limits of his magical
abilities after being expelled
Grindelwald was intent on achieving
higher and higher levels of power his
mission for power eventually landed him
in Godric's Hollow England when he
arrived in Godric's Hollow
he met Albus Dumbledore in the two were
inseparable during the time that they
spent together the two were able to
learn a lot from one another reaching
new heights with regards to magical
ability they had a lot in common
each is ambitious as the other not only
that but both boys shared a common goal
to seek out and acquire all three of the
Deathly Hallows the cloak the wand and
the stone they wanted to lead a
Wizarding revolution that would
effectively put an end to the
International statute of secrecy
breaking down a secretive divided
between muggle and magical world but
when things went awry Grindelwald and
Dumbledore parted ways at this point in
time Grindelwald stalled the Elder Wand
from eqq Gourevitch and set off on the
mission alone operating under the slogan
for the greater good
so given Grunwald's innate magical
talent and possession of the Elder Wand
surely he should be able to cast
Patronus charm right a Patronus as a
result of a witch or wizard casting the
Patronus charm there are two types of
Patronus charm
corporeal and incorporeal patronesses
the more basic form of the spell is the
incorporeal Patronus which assumes no
animal form and simply resembles a burst
of white vapor or smoke the more
advanced form the spell is the conjuring
of a corporeal Patronus the ability to
successfully cast a corporeal Patronus
is considered an impressive feat in the
Wizarding community the corporeal
Patronus assumes the form of the witch
or Wizards spirit animal and varies
extensively from which to witch or
wizard - wizard Harris is a stag runs is
a Jack Russell Terrier and Hermione's is
not a excetera while casting spells that
create your very own spirit animal is
probably fun there is a purpose and that
purpose is to ward off Dementors or
leather folds dark creatures that feed
on human happiness and incite a feeling
of despair and anyone that gets close to
them they are among the first creatures
around and represent nothing but
darkness depression and decay the
Patronus charm is the only known way of
dealing with a Dementor and so it's a
gravely important thing for which or was
it to know the Patronus represents
everything that a Dementor doesn't hope
happiness survival and purity as the
Patronus itself does not feel despair or
hopelessness as a human might the
Dementors can't hurt it and are repelled
by its presence okay so it's an
impressive magical feat that should be
no problem for a wizard as impressive as
Grindelwald right the thing with him is
that it's not quite so straightforward
though I'm divided on this matter I do
tend to slightly lean towards him being
able to produce a Patronus here's why in
order to produce a Patronus one cannot
rely only on their magical ability they
also need to understand concepts of love
and happiness these are things that
someone like Voldemort would have no
concept of and while Voldemort ingre and
the world are often compared as forces
of evil Grindelwald had more humanity
Voldemort is just as dark and evil as a
Dementor and so it makes sense that he
would not be able to produce something
that could combat them Voldemort's only
joy came from doing terrible things he
was never happy even in childhood and
never got to experience true love or
- leaving him with no concept of either
Grindelwald on the other hand did find
love in his life and his ambitions of
establishing a new world order were not
driven by notions of evil or darkness
Grindelwald genuinely felt that what he
was doing was important for the world
and that is why his slogan was for the
greater good he recognized that a lot of
his actions were wrong but ultimately
believed that his mission to establish
the global Wizarding hierarchy was
important for wizard kind he felt that
he was just helping his people so
despite all of the dark and twisted
magic the Grindelwald performed he did
understand love and so I think that if
he were faced with the Dementor he would
be able to cast a Patronus he's
definitely got the magical talent and he
has the emotional intelligence with that
out of the way that leaves one question
what is his Patronus animal in my last
video I established the Patronus animal
can be pretty much anything this is
supported with the following information
from potable no reliable system for
projecting the form of an individual's
Patronus has ever been found although
the great 18th century researcher of
charms professor catalase spangle set
forth certain principles that are widely
accepted as true the Patronus asserted
spangle represents that which is hidden
unknown but necessary within the
personality here says Bengal is the
explanation for the appearance of
patronesses informs that there caster's
might not expect for which they have
never felt a particular affinity or even
recognized it is usual but not
inevitable for Petronas to take the form
of an animal commonly found in the
caster's native country given their long
affinity with humans it is perhaps
unsurprising
among the most common patronesses
although it must be remembered that any
corporeal petronas is highly unusual are
dogs cats and horses extinct patronesses
are very rare but not unknown strangely
given their long connection with wizard
kind al patronesses are unusual most so
in common of all possible patronesses
are magical creatures such as dragons
thestrals and Phoenix's while a rare and
magical Petronas undoubtedly reflects an
unusual personality it does not follow
that it is more powerful or will enjoy
greater success
it's Casta so if a Patronus can be
anything
surely a powerful and truly unique
wizard such as Grindelwald would have a
powerful and unique Patronus to match
we know that Albus Dumbledore's Patronus
was a Phoenix which was revealed to us
when he wanted to summon Hagrid after
Viktor Krum was stunned this probably
came to you as no surprise given that
Dumbledore had an affinity with this
particular creature after all his own
animal companion was the enigmatic and
loyal Phoenix Forks my first theory for
Grindelwald Patronus is that like a
Dumbo doll he shares the Phoenix
Patronus a golden Phoenix in his youth
green default was the golden boy he had
long golden locks of hair he had so much
magical talent and a long and full life
ahead of him the following quote from
the deathly hallows describes
Grindelwald in his youth and there on
the window ledge sat perched like a
giant bird a young man with golden hair
in the split second that the lanterns
light illuminated him Harry saw the
delight upon his handsome face then the
intruder shot a stunning spell from his
wand and jumped neatly backwards out of
the window with a crow of laughter
here's how I came to the conclusion that
his Patronus is a golden Phoenix first
of all it fits his physical
characteristics he has long golden locks
and the passage above explained that he
sat perched like a giant bird next the
Phoenix is a particularly powerful and
rare creature which i think is befitting
of Grindelwald character and lastly
Grindelwald had a deep connection to
Dumbledore and so it makes sense that
the Patronus animals are the same in
Harry Potter we later find out Snape's
Patronus animal is the same as Lily
Evans Lily Evans loved James Potter and
her happiest memory probably had
something to do with him which made her
Patronus a doe and because Snape was
obsessed with Lily his Patronus animal
was the same as hers even though
Grindelwald and Dumbledore parted ways I
think that it's extremely likely that
like Snape Grindelwald still held
Dumbledore close to him and for this
reason I think that his patron s animal
would mimic dumb models my next theory
is less supported by facts but I think
that it's a bit of fun in fantastic
beasts we seek renewal to use a powerful
magical spell called protego diabolica
another strange mausoleum
protego diabolica is a dark spell it
creates a ring of protective black fire
around the target anyone who is an enemy
of the caster will be instantly
incinerated when they try to enter the
circle the spell eventually escalates
into what can only be described as a
fiery winged demon similar to fiend fire
it's mentioned that if the spell hadn't
been stopped by the combined efforts of
the protagonists that it would have
destroyed all of Paris my thought is
that this fiery winged demon that we see
being produced from his protego
diabolica is somehow symbolic and
representative of Grindelwald because we
know that a rare and magical Patronus
usually reflects an unusual personality
and because we know that there are no
limitations on what a Patronus can
actually be i think that Grindelwald
Patronus could perhaps be whatever
creature it is that protego diabolica
produces it looks like some sort of
fiery winged demon or dragon and I
honestly think that this fits
Grindelwald perfectly we know that
demons exist in Harry Potter as they are
a known classification of dark magical
creature so I wouldn't put it past
Grindelwald one of the most powerful
dark wizards of all time to have a
Patronus animal like a demon though I
like the idea of the second theory I do
tend to lean more towards the former
that his Patronus is a Phoenix what do
you guys think do you think that
Grindelwald was able to cast a Patronus
if you agree what was his Patronus
animal let me know down in the comments
section below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
you